cool man yeah this is it
it's been well it's been it's been yeah
yeah gee it's a talk to me man obviously
and you spoke about the cloven ting I've
intentionally not asked you at all today
about the clever thing okay yeah to keep
your topic cuz I don't want to ruin the
entire conversation that's cool
save it yes sir the name is called seen
seen same as EE n SC s as s EE and a
seem that safe seen as in music movie
scene OSCE movie scene all right that's
what I thought all right ignore me ya
Hussain see ya same like it because it's
like it's um it's sounds serious
but people say like specially from like
in the UK or like Jamaican background
you say scene as in I understand yeah
yeah
calm man I like you so why did you how
did you come up with that massively
because I'm into music so when people
relate to movie music scene hmm and also
there's there's so many reasons like the
way I think is I come to a conclusion or
I come to result over multiple things
that connect I connect the dots
basically hmm and once it all make sense
logically in my head it becomes a thing
to me okay so like massive into music
the music singer UK music scene yeah
yeah so yeah decide to run with that
because simply because that reason it
seemed to make sense
cool man so obviously wonders but to do
everyday bobbers in the barbers he said
that what was it he said they won't
start clothing line
yeah but before that you said you want
to get back into private design so
obviously those two intertwine yeah but
did you want to get back into design
because you want style clothing line or
did you want to start clothing line
because you want to get back in design
or there too
two separate entities the way I see it
is I've always wanted to be involved in
design no matter what was well for his
painting drawing past wall paint
wherever it was mmm I wanted to be back
doing art and design mm-hmm I find that
art InDesign very different but I feel
that design is more for a purpose where
I can be simply for the expression just
especially and I'm hoping to combine the
two which I feel like most artists and
designers do is they combine it
seriously expressing something for
purpose good right you know there's
actually sounded sick like I I just used
the time on designing because it's just
a term okay just like drama base R&B
rhythm blues because think R&B is one
thing in it you don't think okay I'm
looking for the rhythm or the you like
to eat someone says Arabi yeah when
Tom's it's R&B you don't think I'm as
two separate things
someone I've never heard anyone say to
me like no the rhythm is this and the
Blues is this and like yay I'm trying to
notice it's like I'm trying to create
rhythm and blues because I like the
rhythm and I like the blues and I want
to marry those together it's just I
that's just our own bees so you're
you're I'm learning yeah that's common
brown learning so it's not like a ticket
design you're trying to marry the two
yeah and the whole clone thing is like
especially we've design I feel like
advertisement boards can be very mundane
they can be like I'm trying to say was
something trying to sell something by
this points to their ranks
whereas I feel like wearing a garment
it's more of it's not advertising in
itself it's I feel like it's more of an
expression rather than trying to sell
something hmm
the reason why were the kind of ethos
behind my design and I have like a code
of ethics I call it okay yeah so I feel
like when you look at fashion label I
should say Prowler mm-hmm or Gucci
mm-hmm
you're seeing them symbols and you're
thinking that's a lot of money you can
get value you've put value to that to
that symbol yeah I don't like that idea
I like the idea of having meaning more
meaning like we were saying like more
content yeah as in it has a message and
has more of a conversation underlying
that statement okay I can't so like you
said it's called scene is it gonna say
scene on the thing or is it you said
it's gonna be like a like an like a
sentence or a phrase or icebreaker
wherever wherever like wasn't like what
like explained that he'd seen that's the
platform yeah that's the name of it but
the ethos was I'll go back to that is I
want to have like a not a six trap line
but an icebreaker
yeah which causes conversation yeah like
when you walk into a club or what you
look at any kind of social environment
it could be going out for a meal and to
see a saying or an expression used like
you could think of any especially in the
UK there's so many expressions that used
both but you know what daily basis I was
watching a YouTube thing ever that have
you ever seen hot ones on YouTube yeah
do you see the Idris Elba one yeah yeah
come on like the other week there's a
bit obviously because he's English in
America the geezer was asking him like
what yeah yeah like he's asking him like
what does he's asking Idris like what
does this mean a name is I obviously
asked typical [ __ ] baked [ __ ] that
was crepes mean but he said like What
did he say he said like what does Bob's
your uncle mean and I was thinking what
do you mean what does Bob's your uncle
you just just a thing in it like you
know what it is why you're asking what
is built your uncle me but he doesn't
know what it means and yet like in this
country especially there's so many
little things that you take for granted
that you just say and you're like yeah
like rule of thumb what does that mean
I actually don't know what that means
and if someone's in fast estimate yeah I
know what yeah I know how to use it if
someone put me on the spot I was like
explain rule of thumb because I don't
get it but even you just saying like
Bob's your uncle
hmm what does that mean it doesn't mean
I can say it yeah yeah but what does it
mean I know how to receive it by I'm
I can't break down I think does it mean
like bombs wrong call me
yeah drunk like Bob's your uncle means
like you're certified like if I said
like are you want to get like if you
want to get big go Jim eat good sleep
good Bob's your uncle
yeah yeah yeah so like that's the
endgame Bob's your uncle is BAE bish
bash Bosh Bob's your uncle
I think these expressions like I
understand them when they said but to
explain them to somebody else like the
reason why I'm using these like these
come icebreakers I guess conversation
starters is that okay so if that's what
you want them to do so when I first come
up the concept there I I know them as
idioms or idioms mm I don't know what
that word means
it's literally just an expression okay
not everybody uses it has like only
people in certain environments like per
se people in the UK would know people
from America with no days you know and
I've decided to roll with that because I
feel like they create interest mm-hmm
and to see a phrase you think I know
that it has a certain like nostalgic
value to it mm-hmm
so that's why I like the idea of using
expressions on t-shirts so that's why
I'm kind of rolling with that as well as
my graphic background of having a symbol
mmm yes I have a symbol that made this
is which is my idea of a product of
creativity which is you for you heard
before is one plus one equals three know
a verb people say Whomper does when he
goes through but never that as a form of
creativity yeah so it's using the two
parts of us um to make more than what it
is gang that sounds dope I've never even
other yeah yeah so so but obviously 1+1
in mathematics logically equals two but
making it three one plus one equals
three is make a product of creativity
making that extra value to it making
something more than what it is like we
were saved like Damien Hirst
mmm-hmm he would spend millions of
pounds on diamonds and curse them onto a
skull the actual value of that skull is
a certain amount but it'll go for walks
and so much more because he's created it
and that's his problem creativity yeah
yeah so I've used that idea that one
plus one equals three use that logically
turn on its side and create a bridge and
to me a bridge bridges the gap between
two places and that's where my self was
coming from fair play but wonder here
I'm gonna see it yeah it's a simple I
like minimalistic I like I'm all about
minimalist you know when something's
over come over complicated that we
explained it sounds over complicated
because of minimal lights it's throwing
much it doesn't simple symbol yeah I
feel ya explaining captures what your
progress is what I need yeah man yeah
that's it and also I've added this
partner symbol is a degree symbol mm-hmm
which have you heard the expression temp
degree M degree I've heard it I don't
know what it means okay so it means to a
certain level yeah yeah like an X level
yes value like an algebra sister level I
mean I've always liked maths yeah that's
why I always refer to logical and maths
and I kind of think so using the degree
symbol to me is just a level that's what
it pretty much says hmm so breeze to a
sound level but if you think about these
things a lot deep again all right man
that's cool everyone not everyone was to
talk over line but obviously that's cool
but you've clearly put a lot if I can go
into it so that's good man actually
because obviously the after years of
design working in the industry's doing
app development and shoe design like
just different industries
I've had a lot of time to think and for
me to put something out I feel like when
you bring yourself or show yourself on a
certain platform you're vulnerable
but it's scary you know I tell you what
you today this is how this is how scary
things are this is to fake embarrassed
to say it but [ __ ] it today so obviously
that's man I'm tree online-based um what
was it
so my Instagram never use I use of
stories and [ __ ] but I don't ever
actually use the Instagram
I don't post [ __ ] and post [ __ ] for
years your doorman I'm doorman because
I've been dormant I created my Instagram
I gave my Instagram when I first made it
when for Instagram first dropped
obviously I was all about fitness it was
all about body building all that [ __ ] so
my entire Instagram is all about fitness
[ __ ] and that was represented in my name
and I obviously still care about fitness
but it's not who I am sure it's not my
identity anymore and Instagram is a is a
representation of your identity in some
aspects if you want it to be which I
would like it to be and I appreciate
when people do that so I need you to get
the fitness out of my name for starters
and literally your Instagram represent
you and there's no two ways to buy it
people can [ __ ] around it and say
there doesn't be it obviously does yeah
of course it does yeah because it's it's
a place where people who don't know you
can't you can't judge you so it needs to
be a an adequate representation of you
because you look at people Instagram you
look at me like he's a prick but you can
do two Scrolls and like he's a prick and
that's a representation of you because
you upload prickers [ __ ] so if you have
a pretty [ __ ] you'll represent in the
prick side of yourself so in sometimes
representation of you mine was had
Fitness in the name I didn't want that
to be the representation of me anymore
but it took me this has been in my head
for weeks and it took me until today
where I literally just like and they're
just like change the name and I was just
like brav like it shouldn't be that deep
but it is a chapter and this year and
he's vulnerable is allowing people to
say like Oh James scratch the fitness
like the change change his name on
Instagram he's trying to portray a new
side of himself vulnerability where it's
very easy to say close I could just left
the Instagram Karen I'm doing what I'm
doing and it's just yeah is is very
vulnerable so yeah like you said doing a
purely creative expression of yourself
extremely vulnerable extremely
vulnerable and it's a bold movement and
I feel like with an online presence you
put a lot of pressure on yourself
because with today's I feel like in
today's society when you're laughing
czar online it's
the only kind of thing people can
reference you to what you're doing in
your life at the minute because nowadays
everyone will our age moved on like you
get to a point where you don't really
see everyone every day it's not like you
in school don't teach everyday people
you're French itself you don't see all
the time so the only way they can
reference back to you is by seeing you
online and what you're doing online bro
I saw a couple you went to school with
online the other day I don't even seen
them since we left and then I saw
they're just random stop popping up on
my suggested and I'm like cool and then
you take people into the life and it are
this person's into this now waist man
this president to this man interesting
this girl's all right now she wasn't all
right before she's all right now
Hey and he's yeah bright that's that's
all you know about them is their
Instagram someone that you used to spend
every single day with and I think when
we just cool that there was no as barely
Facebook there was MySpace yeah MSN and
mr. was before MySpace Amazon was before
MySpace but that wasn't like a
representation of yourself that's just
moving to take yeah so profile picture
chat to people that I just spent all day
with sandal emoji yeah yeah yeah send
they're quite emoji trying some breasts
on camera that was me never worked and
calm and then myspace and welcome bra
webcam when it was just like you'd move
like that embarrassing all my days yeah
webcam was the [ __ ] but bro like that's
actually mad so yeah you had all these
like outlets of people that you you
didn't even know and then beginning days
people went out here just flexing their
true personalities they'd be taking
pictures of bogus [ __ ] and even then it
was like a massive vulnerability I
remember mr. Church I remember when I I
like I've always been obsessed with like
creative outlets and stuff right even
though I've never you wouldn't know me
you wouldn't know but like well not
knowing me you wouldn't know for example
but only a few people know if I've been
obsessed with it but like when myspace
first dropped or when we was on myspace
back in the day I went through his face
where I was doing like little
sketches and skits and [ __ ] I ended up
uploading loads of them stripped him all
back because I fought you man are gonna
cost me
these men are definitely gonna cuss what
were they of the random [ __ ] random [ __ ]
like I had a I think I had one
compression box
yeah you're proficient I love it I had
one where I was boxing with my dog you
just when we were boxing like a lot and
I had one was just like a hilarious
boxing episode with my dog but the [ __ ]
thing was is that I didn't have no video
editing software so I had to like do two
second clips and stuff like that I'm
like and I don't even know if at the
time it's video and from my space days
that's quite forward I said I don't even
know if it did video at that time I
think it was just pictures so I had to
like snap mad pics or create like a
whole album of something like that and
like have little captions that worked
animation yeah like a new animation
thing and every caption would understand
what's going on trying to write like
funny captions and it was just like this
guy's a [ __ ] but it was to me I would
look at it read it and find it
unbearably funny but an hour four is one
of them things where I find it fine
couple you ma'am might find it funny but
even if you did you wouldn't tell me
that was funny you just take it down you
like a [ __ ] of you know I feel like
with you like your sense of humor is um
you get the commercial jokes you'll get
Joe mean what's it called who you so
much overtime Rick James [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah about that but there's
also a sense of humor that are your
niche among people will find funny but I
find awkwardness funny for one I find
time in hilarious like timing for me
that's a British thing that it is a
British thing is a bridge string because
you know like perfect examples like the
you know the office the British office
the old tank
I find that unbearably funny yeah so
many people find the America more
funnier I find English more fun yet
because the time in like that the other
day I was at work
Photoshop Photoshop yeah yeah and like
my what was I doing
my boss some a comment we had a new girl
basically had a new girl start or
something
she was on she was talking to a client
on the phone and she'd never spoken to
someone without any of the coaching or
anything like that was our first time
govern live with a client they're open
to questions anything like she's nervous
and [ __ ] so she goes on there I'm sat
here she's that there my boss is sat
behind in a different like cubicle
wherever a quadrant whatever you want to
[ __ ] call it so she finishes her call
and my boss says over like our nights
well like no it's nice nice that was
good and then the girls are what was
that and like immediately she was our
nothing I just checked my cell phone
number
but like the sentence that she said is
not that funny
but the speed in which she was able to
like regurgitate that was hella witty
and I was crying but it's something
about timing just just that's it though
just like I find it's a well-known thing
that in like comedy and timing is
everything literally it's the amount of
pause yeah man timing is everything in
comedy it it really is and I find that
obviously I listen to a lot of podcasts
often a lot of ones I actually listened
to our run by comedians and then natural
time you can tell why they got into
comedy because a lot than 10 natural
timing is what makes them funny so when
I actually think are they're funny let
me ask you what's their like stand ups
and [ __ ] on Netflix I'll watch it I'm
thinking I actually find that funny
because that's rehearsed they've
rehearsed that so their timing isn't
genuine is rehearsed yeah and then like
I'm not yeah yeah I'd agree with that
bit I say even with a script like scrubs
scrubs funny it's fine don't get me
wrong but you can rehearse timing don't
wrong some of them I find a bro
Dave Chappelle did a new one the other
day he's standup unbearably funny
and that's rehearse but I find rehearse
[ __ ] funny too but you have to nail it
like you have to nail it if I feel like
you're nervous and you're half a
millisecond off I'm like yeah you have
to just bang and there's what some
comedians I find is sometimes how
relaxed they are and how mundane they
are sometimes how relaxed they are with
what they say it's like that's pretty
funny dude especially if it's genuine
and relaxation as well I was another guy
who the Deaf kind of remember its name
but he was you could tell his character
was that very much like lo a great guy
now he's actually white guy okay but he
was very much like depressive and down
and stuff like that but that's his
character but you can tell that's not
him but he pulls it off but not 100% so
he's not home as a genuine because you
can tell ten minutes before he got on
stage he was hype and then you got on
stage just like mask on show yeah this
is a show and he's playing that but
because you can I don't know how you can
tell you can just tell this is his
character that he's trying to play it's
not like you know I'm not finally the
funniest now where if someone actually
is like that like my brother Lima Bravo
he'd like he's just all the time he's
just blank and he'll just say [ __ ]
that's just like straight out and then I
find out where he's been as well but
hundreds in all his life he's been like
that so when he does it I'm laughing
because that's just who he is funny
sometimes things things he says go over
my head sometimes uh-huh and then if
anyone on our right I got you [ __ ]
my brother thinks he's the smartest lab
on the planet is it why yeah he's clever
though oh great me yeah mom
so when's the I was gonna go on
something you're saying there's
something to do with a comedian thing
mm-hmm
I remember now you [ __ ] me before my
fly now I was just gonna say what's the
get like what's the what's the like well
first of all where you at
production-wise or design-wise or yeah
with the clothes and [ __ ] and the mayor
in a minute the gum has been printed
after just create some labels the labels
are waving and you know like NFL we're
in the fair NBA jerseys mmm well they
have the little information thing at the
bottom of the Jersey I'm going with that
okay and I feel like the
I feel like because I've always been
into sport and the whole I've say the
whole look of sports clothing mm-hmm is
attractive
oh yeah yeah so I'm gonna have this kind
of sport detail on the bottom
mm-hm just to for a bit of information
rather than so plain T as different
dynamics to it and then I'm having so
yeah there have there been imported in a
minute
hopefully they'll drop on Thursday and
then they'll get their labels put on the
following week so it still still be made
that's further than I thought but I
thought it was just concept at the
minute
no we're good to go yeah much well give
me three weeks and will this work this
this podcast won't come out until after
that anyway this is gonna come out
longer than three weeks okay so I'm
gonna time backlog in a few Somali I've
got a little gap where I'm about to
record a few so your your we're gonna be
flowing by the time this dress we're
gonna be flowing so I'll make sure all
the information before I ready all the
informations on it we're gonna be good
to go you're gonna get sales you're
gonna get sale yours
I don't I want people to understand the
meaning more than just going for it yeah
you know I feel like just be good to
understand the code of ethics yeah but
that's why you said you was doing your
own little content as well and that's
part that's what's to like talk to me
about the club because I didn't even ask
you I was like two hours today yeah so
like what's the what we've been talking
about so each school scene I'm go over
series and episode mmm s1e one yeah yeah
so season one is presence and creating a
present being present and that's what
the scene one it's all about okay so
it's like did you mean like online
presence or just all types of press
being present be having an online
presence this is the whole idea of being
present
okay calm you know because have you ever
seen Muji it's a Muji
it's a guy he's on YouTube
he's very spiritual oh yeah he talks
about being self being yourself
we know one and he's talked a very
spiritual mm-hmm and I find that
sometimes people day-to-day get caught
up in it literally in the hustle and
bustle in the midst of things and
they'll get stressed out both down and
if you just take a few minutes just to
just chill out and just be present being
that moment and realize there's some
things out your control mmm and just be
present I find helps yeah yeah yeah bro
100% mom like in terms of being present
another tangent I need to go off that
you just said that just spikes off in my
head that needs to remember but in terms
of being present like that's why this is
halting in the first place
because like I find it so rare in my
day-to-day life that I can have a
conversation in which I am 100% present
like I'm actually listening to what
you're saying like I'm not on the phone
listening and type in I'm not they want
three four different people chatting
over here when I'm trying to listen to
what you're saying I'm not at work
trying to listen to you while I'm in
between talking to people yeah yeah yeah
I'm not like on my lunch break
I've got like 15 minutes to talk like
say what you want to say if you go off
an attention you need to get back to
what the point you were trying to make
is because we haven't got time like
there's so many times that I wish I
could get into [ __ ] and talk about stuff
yeah and just you don't have the
opportunity and then that's the same
like my boy Luis mmm we have this
routine where we'll go this has been
going on for like a year or two now in
which we were go to gym we'll go to work
because obviously used to work in the
gym so a good work would train after
work and then would go for a swim we did
[ __ ] all swimming would get into the
pool and we just chat will probably do
like a length and then while we're
catching a breath with his chat bro
would be in there for hours and we're
talking because this is the only time
that no one's gonna interrupt us I'm in
the pool so no one's got my phone ain't
near me like there's no time frame
there's not even a clock in there so I
don't even know what time it is and
we're just chat and we got so much
interesting converse
and unlike so much motivate in chat and
all this stuff and then that was when I
decided like I need to do this because
Matt times I was just saying to him like
right we've been speaking for three
hours
that's a podcast episode done like we've
just as like he's like I don't have this
opportunity to do this for anyone yeah
and it's like so interesting
yeah have that opportunity to be present
in a conversation you take so much more
from it definitely and I think is
important to have those types of people
around you yes like we say before before
we started the connecting dots like when
you feel like you have a common ground
with someone and you have a similar
interest in same creative outlets or
just interested in general yeah I feel
like it's very important to keep that
not constant all the time but in the
flow you know so when I don't see your
barbershop I knew that me and you could
sit in a barber shop
Felicia like for four hours three four
hours just chain bro and that's the peak
thing as well the probe is on that you
mentioned the barber shop per for the
example that you mentioned is because I
knew you were nearly done and you were
gonna go and I was if I was gonna jump
in the in the chair I purposely didn't
ask you questions that were gonna lead
into a long conversation even though I
wanted to don't read one there was a
dress they actually are because you have
to kind of you don't know what I was
doing niche don't know if they have to
make an appointment
how would I do a pre in prison it's a
few and far between that you actually
present yeah just like a barbershop was
used up for it for example you didn't
know what I was doing after so you
didn't know what talk about because you
did know how long I had yeah yeah I
don't wanna make you feel uncomfortable
thinking that I've got a going man
please like and it's just like it's
awkward because obviously we've been
boys since we were like 11 and I can go
two years of our senior and then bump
into you and we'll talk for as long as
we we can talk for but like yeah in that
situation barbershop by which it was
perfect by stupid because it's so ready
you have the opportunity to just spend
ages talking to someone you just like
you know I'm not even gonna ask the
questions that are long-winded I'm just
gonna make sure you're alright see we're
up to and then just the dread thing
about that is sometimes with what they
called there's more talk mmm a small
town a small talk it has the content
needs to be initiated
because you need to say you're right
yeah yeah tell me it's that simple you
alright it's small talk and it can be
like yeah I'm fine
and I feel like depending on how the
person responds to you hmm
just kind of shows you where they are ha
bird that's true and the fingers as well
I hate small talk and I hate people that
under don't understand small talk as
well so like for example no you need to
know your place so this is [ __ ] at work
she's not [ __ ] but she actually know
she's a [ __ ] at this is the reason
she's a [ __ ] every time I speak to her
I don't know her we work in different
departments so the only time that I will
see her is in passing so if all like we
just happen to be stood still at the
same place like we might be cure for
food or we might be doing something I
might be heating something up in the
microwave she's making a coffee and I'm
so so I'll one we're stuck in an awkward
situation but we've only were neither be
here for 30 seconds I'll be like are you
right her response every time mmm no not
really
but you find it entertaining because you
like awkwardness no but I find it funny
yeah in retrospect yeah I find it funny
in retrospect but in the position that
I'm in I know I don't have time to ask
you why you're not alright you know I
don't have time to ask you why you're
not alright so why the [ __ ] you saying
you're not alright I don't yeah I'm
because I don't care if you're alright I
just said you right because I'm saying
you're right I'm not even asking you are
you okay I'm saying you're right yeah
it's just so annoying but like that's
why I hate small talk but I find that
when I've delivered to a place called oh
it's good heat reamers mm-hmm it's one
girl I deliver to so you're right
similar similar situation yeah bacon you
she's chumming the water ask questions
you know what's got in your personal
life you're here for your work yeah I'm
here to console you about the personal
life say yes and leave me literally say
yes and leave me alone
ranae's when it's elongated yeah more
questions no questions I'm just saying
you were right but yeah like I think
that's a case of like know your place in
terms of who you are who we are as
people as well don't
all comfortable like I said I say some
people get to contour too quick crazy
comfortable I don't like it
even like it's not stupid say but even
that small little aspect of saying yeah
I'm okay
expecting me to ask you follow questions
you're too comfortable this is yo you've
not done anything per se but you're too
comfortable yeah quite a lot sometimes
people just get too far too quickly yeah
sometimes that makes it feel like
they're lonely as hell as well you know
I mean yeah yeah like for you to be so
desperate for me to want to art like I'm
a random person in your life and you
clearly want me to ask you follow-up
questions
in-depth personal questions about your
life who are you missing in your life
that you can't like unload to yeah I
feel like it's okay to be lonely as long
as you're humbly lonely okay so that
makes sense you know maybe like say
let's say old people some people I like
old people because they want to talk
yeah yeah but they don't force it on you
yeah young people yeah yeah young people
corny but right
[ __ ] sake yeah and then like this
reminds me this is more - a perfect
example of cornering when I was on
tinder before I do tinder yeah when I
was on tinder before one of our pet
peeves I paid off so many girls I agreed
to meet them PI them all off because
when we were chatting his [ __ ] wants to
corner me like she she will say like
what is it
I don't know although they might upload
something on this story or they might do
something that is trim in the war so
that I can swim in and burlap Basil's
wrong like I hate when people upload a
random story like why have people such
pricks and then just leave it like that
that's not that hasn't made you feel any
better by putting that on there
you haven't unloaded anything on there
you trim in the war you want people you
want a million people to ask you what's
wrong and then corner them into being a
stuck in a situation that they don't
even want to be in but if I don't ask
you what's wrong
you know if we're in the talking stage
and you've done that you've baited me
and I'm the one you're talking to and I
want you to show you show her that you
can get she knows she's got my little
face in there too seen the story when
she goes back and checks who's seen the
story it would be like my little face
don't say like 98 people or some [ __ ]
like that
and she seen my face and blah blah this
[ __ ] saw that I'm in a bad place and
didn't even ask me like I don't call me
like that
don't put me in the situation let me be
genuine and let me ask you yeah I hate I
hate [ __ ] like that and that's something
yeah like when you said humbly alone or
something like that like if you if you
want to express yourself if you want to
unload if you want to do suffer like
that like that's fine but find the right
person that's there to do that with
don't corner people into forcing your
negative [ __ ] in it I don't like to hear
negative she all day and Jim barber he's
actually real good he's actually real
good and not unloading his negative XI
on me he's a he's a professional and
every single time we talked we spoke
about slow-roasted barbers they are
professionals in social environments
they are they are they've like got that
status of they know the [ __ ] they're
around the [ __ ] they also run the
positive stuff so they kind of
orchestrate yeah yeah yeah hundred
percent every time I talk to him I say
he'll say how are you and I'm like yeah
man all good even though I could be
going through hell I'm not gonna burden
him with what's going on in my my life
so he'll say what's going on man all
good and humble are we sending him black
yeah man
can't complain that's cheap every time
right yeah man can't complain
I'm like he definitely can complain but
you've worried yeah yeah definitely good
if you want you I'm sure you've got a
lot of [ __ ] going on in your life that
you could want to complain about but I'm
hot I'm grateful that you're not
burdening me with that and we ended up
having a conversation about at one time
in that he said I said to him like you
always say can't complain I liked it and
he was like yeah man because I shouldn't
complain I shouldn't be complaining
especially of all people I shouldn't be
complaining to you and like ya shouldn't
be complaining to you and on my
appreciate mmm because too many people
are faster corny you and and treat me
like I'm your it's interesting though it
seems like
because this whole scene thing is I feel
like when I said it's about the music
scene or movie scene or whatever to me I
feel like I am quite a deep thinker and
I feel that it's also it also goes hand
in hand with culture as in music does
influence culture yeah yeah yeah and
cultures in your barber shop that is
part of the culture mmm like people that
go to a barber shop there's a huge
amount of people I feel but that I think
that get low-cut haircut every we'll say
three weeks maximum max two pieces for
me yeah two weeks but we say three weeks
just in case it might be busy that some
people yeah but there's kind of
environment I feel like it's not enough
conversation there's not enough things
being addressed in those environments
that I feel like especially with this
era need to be expressed you know why as
well you know my I feel as well I also
feel where we are in a time at now where
it's more acceptable to disagree with
someone's opinion than it is to agree
with them or try to agree is it's more
acceptable to just hard-faced disagree
then try to empathize and see someone
else's point of view and I think that
actually pulls conversation to a whole
like for the first time bar shot perfect
example I was actually in there a couple
months ago and what happened Fox I don't
know why I ended up happening and I hate
the fact that happened no matter what
you say it's not going to surprise me
because anything goes in a prior
everything on it we've gotten to the two
topics that in a barbash limb you just
can't be asked to get the topic of one
was religion especially that [ __ ]
barbershop you don't wanna County and
the second one was education in it okay
basically say football okay I ain't got
time to argue about football friends
better and more important things I'll
have to be arguing there for [ __ ]
football okay but now these were deep
conversations
basically I was I was tired of
homosexuality is how it got onto the
topic so actually that's a touchy
subject
religion homosexuality and education all
piled into one conversation wasn't
getting my haircut broth broth but I was
trying my best to empathize sounds like
a long trip it started when I was in the
sea as well so it's not even like I
could get involved see two people get
the haircut then get my haircut and then
no it was one of us was in mercy and you
could tell because he once gets point
across so bad he's slowing down on the
fade in it because I'm just anyway so it
started off with something on the news
that we were watching and we were
talking about something to do with like
like a transgender movement or something
like that and he was trying to say like
the media will promote trans or gay or
anything like that more than it will
promote conventional marriage and I was
trying to say yeah because commercial
marriage is boring yeah
from a media perspective boy yeah what
if who's gonna read it's the norm yeah
who's gonna read about this couple got
married conventionally yesterday yeah
traditional marriage in a Catholic
Church well done Sarah and Jim like who
no one gives a [ __ ] so yes they're gonna
promote transgender because it's a it's
a it's a sketchy subject still it's an
interesting subject still so basically
he tried to go onto the topic about how
long story short the schools are
influencing it too much they're
promoting it too much they shouldn't be
allowed to educate people about
homosexuality and transgenders they're
convincing them that it's okay to do
these things agree you think I feel like
people are more acceptable to it now but
do you think that's an issue it's not
it's not an issue that's the thing
that's what he was trying to say and I
agree with I agree with the fact that
schools are trying to make it seem more
acceptable but I think that's a good
thing whereas he said that's a bad thing
he thinks because obviously in he's a
Muslim so like I don't want to find any
Muslim people
listening to me taught by this office is
just my opinion is that in Muslim
culture or in least in here I can't
speak for miserably in his opinion
choice being gay or all these things are
a choice yeah and I I'd try not to speak
for ages because I just don't want to
get your tongue yes how was Brad I want
to get into this yeah and then it got to
the point where as I [ __ ] this man I'm
gonna have to say something in it
because he's just is just I don't know
why he's you don't get rolled up by
people's opinions but I don't like I
don't like hearing people duck that I
don't feel like know all the facts and I
talking more from what they think they
know than what they actually know and if
I can hear them spewing references
obviously cuz we're ending people on the
back at that point they're gonna use
references so reference this reference
that reference that and if they're gonna
use references that I know for a fact
are untrue then I'm gonna have to step
in now I can't I can't let that lie yeah
it's almost like well I feel like we've
really some is different though okay
religion because obviously with religion
you were your beliefs are from literally
from a book you know Wade she says in
black and white this is wrong
yeah and anything that goes against what
the book says is gonna be wrong hmm
sorry you don't convince him otherwise I
don't want to convince him I want him to
be umph empathetic to other people's
opinions so like what you've just done
Eve empathized with a Muslim person
having those opinions right exactly
exactly so what you've done is a mature
way to have a debate or a conversation
you you say your point of view they say
their points of view you empathize with
them if you can sometimes you could just
can't because some people just done but
on the rare occasion that you can't most
times you should be able to empathize
where they're coming from if they've if
they've made them so clear enough they
should be able to express themself
enough so that you can empathize and
then you can I choose to agree with them
change your mind and be on their side or
you can say okay I understand we come
from about complete disagree and then
you guys can leave it amicably from
there and hopefully they can empathize
with you
in that situation there was no such
thing it was very much him being on the
stance of buffers down this is wrong I
don't want to hear anyone that thinks is
not
is stupid and they're like going to hell
basically and that's very that's why I
don't like getting into religious topics
with religious people because they are
like you said it's there's no gray areas
it's a standpoint this is right and
you're wrong and we're never gonna have
a mature conversation about that and I
think that's what rile me up because I
for I mean this is not a conversation
we're having here you want me to just
agree with you and you're asking me like
obviously I don't want to speak but he's
like inner James any Jane this is wrong
because of this any James I'm like I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie say yeah
yeah yeah when that's not how I feel
yeah and I was trying to say to him I
feel the use of belief is used to of
religion so when you talk about religion
and stuff like that and this is how what
I believe is true I think the term
belief should be open to if that's what
how you truly believe and if you truly
have faith in Islam or Christianity or
stuff like that you shouldn't be afraid
of putting that under some stress if you
if you truly believe in something if
that's your truth then you shouldn't be
adverse to put in that under some strain
so he would rather for example he's
talking about his son and he he can
raise this on how he wants and he was
saying he doesn't want schools even
mentioning gay people mentioning trans
people because he thinks if his son is
surrounded by it or educated about it
then he won't that he might be more
inclined to choose that path and he
wants to dedicate his path to this
because this is the part of Islam and
stuff like that and what I was trying to
say to him is if you've raised your son
as a Muslim and he truly believes in
Islam and he's old enough to understand
the rules and regulations of being a
Muslim then it shouldn't matter if
someone's telling him about it because
he truly believes that Islam is the way
to go and it wouldn't matter what anyone
else says because he truly believes that
that is wrong if he truly believes that
homosexuality is wrong and you shouldn't
have any issue with the education about
it and he was trying to say now because
then he might choose and then I'm like
my friends then he doesn't believe in
Islam then does he
you can argue the point
let's say to say you believe in God you
believe in Jesus or any kind of deity
yeah mmm you don't want your child to be
in a school where they do dazzl dev
devil worship in that's true you know so
in them I find that with certain
religions being gay
he's part of the evilness we've been
named that's true so that's how they see
it so he doesn't want his son being
around
evil basically yeah that's true but he's
also the one that chose to send him to
that school in the sense of a Muslim
school he's ended on public school and
that's just the dice you roll like you
can make that argument which is fine but
you sent him to that school and you're
not willing to homeschool him so what we
arguing about that's what that was the
point I was trying to make as well
because he was like oh you wouldn't see
that in a Christian school they don't
talk about that one right yeah because
they sent him to a Christian school but
you did send just on to a Christian
school or Muslim schools like that you
sent into a standard public school where
the beliefs in that school have that
system and you knew that when you signed
him up - yeah so I think that's like
having a kid even send him to a certain
school or even just let him out into the
world I don't think it's right to
completely bubble wrap the person no
matter where they go
well this is the thing I was trying to
say to him cuz he was talking about
brainwash that's how we got into the
topic of education he said education is
a form of brainwashing and I was like
okay you need to tell me this and then
he was like he was trying to say that by
the fact that they're educating people
about homosexuality being transgender or
anything like that is a form of
brainwashing and I was trying to say no
offense brother but I think you denying
people in an education is more
brainwashing then telling them the whole
story I said as long as they're not
outright telling your son you should be
gay then they're not brainwashing him
there's a saying there are gay people
there are lesbian people there are
bisexual people there are transgender
people and this is the world we live in
and all these people exist but if you're
saying you don't want him to know gay
people exist you don't want him to know
this you don't want to know that you
only want him to know the teachings of
Islam mean anything that's evil you
don't want him exposed to you want him
here
in my opinion that's more of a form of
brainwashing it's not because he doesn't
know anything
yes because you've brainwashed him to
only know what you want him to know
that's more brainwashing than giving him
an entire education about the world
because the fact is wherever you teach
him I buy or not it exists he's gonna
meet a gay dude in his life a hundred
percent unless you lock him in the
basement for the rest of his life that's
brainwash yeah we're talking
brainwashing here but obviously he
didn't see my point of view and that's
why it ended up being like a two-hour
conversation about nothing and you don't
want to get into touchy subjects in I
don't even how we gone to this topic but
that's fine that's fine
I feel like conversations booting about
a barber or Katrine that's what I'm
trying to say I was trying to say is
basically sorry to get back to my point
I was actually trying to make in the
first place is the point I'm trying to
make is that I feel we live in a society
where it's too easy to be like nope
wrong you're wrong I'm not listening to
this and that's why people are less
inclined to give their true opinions
about something but other fear of being
ganged up on if you're in a public area
like a barber shop I was the only one
defending myself in that whole situation
this was me and four Muslim brothers and
a couple silent people in the back so
I'm the only one that's got this opinion
and everyone else to try and tell me now
and that's an that's er I can intimidate
in situation to be and if you don't feel
comfortable in the situation and I feel
like we live in a time now where it's
very easy and it's almost encouraged
that if you have a Stern opinion you
fight off anyone who doesn't have that
opinion if we're on different teams if
we have different opinions we're on
different teams so is about me either
convincing you or tell you to sharp like
this is a wall and when you're not
penetrating it whereas I would rather be
like okay cool let's everyone
dish it out like I wanna hear I want to
hear someone in the back be like well
actually I disagree with you because of
this this and this and this and I won't
hear another people like yeah actually I
know I agree with half of what you said
but I actually will agree with this bit
of what you said I hate when people are
so team-based and even if they're in the
back of their mind if they're on the
blue team and the red team's over here
even if they agree there might disagree
with 99% of all the red team ones once
but they might agree with one percent
they'll never say it they'll never know
they don't wanna become that middle gray
area there no must have been a gram I
don't wanna know about that yeah no I
want to be careful bro they want to be
rid of
yeah hey hey I feel like it's people
should be more okay with being
individual being an individual who has
the same opinion as this person but also
agrees with the opposite side hmm
you know and that's why I try and
empathize with both sides but I agree
with you when once when people are part
of a culture mmm Pavin like a religious
group hmm it's difficult to open their
mind because they're already structured
in that format
yeah but hundred percent it's tough man
I didn't want to get into that
conversation I knew it wasn't gonna end
well
but boy yeah it's ace mad I keep it with
Jimmy
Oh every time I mean in I've been
getting my hair cut since him since I
was like 14 15 that's the only time
we've ever got into a deep conversation
and that's probably the last time we'll
ever get into a conversation that's why
I always keep it like this with Jim
whenever I speak to him must be talking
about going Jim mmm I say look you still
going Jim we've done a layman going to
conversations like that yeah if he's
your barber you wouldn't give you nice
trim yeah everyone want to keep everyone
happy
yeah you want to keep him as nice as
possible yeah yeah well this thing up a
little bit yeah yeah
but brother yeah but it's Matt I was
gonna say something I was actually gonna
say something that you mentioned the
other thing you said about the comedian
thing now I what was it I feel like with
comedians it's there for more expression
I understand which I mean so in a sense
they're they're expressing themselves
and people that are naturally funny and
will make you laugh person that's
naturally funny doesn't have to say much
Arbour min and more could be said
because of their presence and them just
being themselves mmm expressing
themselves just make some automatically
in that funny category yeah man i 100%
agree and like a lot a lot of the people
that I respect the most in comedy in
comedy and in life the reason they're
funny is because like I said I live
there so authentic and that is just like
a true expression of their personnel
yeah like when I was said I've watched
the Dave Chappelle thing the other day
like he says some [ __ ] on there he could
go to jail for but he's willing to say
do you agree with some people think
comedians should say certain topics or
two about certain things I think
everyone should say whatever I think
anything goes I think there are places
in which anything doesn't go but if you
can choose to be in that situation if I
chose to put III agree in that if
someone decides to listen to this our
conversation now they've chosen they
have the ability to turn us off you can
press back yes they can skip us they can
cancel us they can do whatever they want
so they don't have a right to tell me
what I can and can't say and I thought
that's the same of comedians you chose
to either be there live or I chose I
chose to put on an ethics of the day so
I mean there's on now I've put myself in
their world in their world so I don't
have a right to dictate what they're
going to say in their world because I
have every right to turn it off if I
don't like it I can turn it off it's
fine now there are situations in which
you need to shake mouth where you're
where you're stuck in an office for
someone and they sit on the desk next to
you and they want to give their
controversial opinions and stuff like
that and it's like I don't have a choice
but to listen to the [ __ ] that's coming
out your mouth yeah I shouldn't have to
put me in that position
I shouldn't I don't want to put anyone
in position where they have no choice
but to listen to what I want to say then
you should keep it mellow you need to
keep it that's why I feel with vanilla
with technology nowadays because we can
flick on to everyone typing where we
want and get information wherever we
want like that when we're in social
environments with people we can where we
often if someone said something we don't
like it's almost like we switch them off
oh yeah yeah close them down yeah and I
find sometimes it helps is it's the
world we live in
mmm it's true man you just mean you're
talking a safe mean you met up somewhere
some guy comes up you trying to know him
he start talking about what he want to
talk about and my head I'm thinking to
close him down close that window press
press X climb trying to talk to you yeah
and I'll give you like a little I'll
probably kick your shoe summer there's
the sign
Dukes I'd like a little Cola crazy
yeah for real I'm sure thing is well I'm
bad my body language is bad in this it
should give off too easily I give it up
so easily how I haven't been taught is
you should not fight that really true
it's true I shouldn't have to people
need to be more aware man it's like
barbaric yes these people need to be
more self aware of the situations that
they're in man like I don't understand
what people are unaware sometimes I
don't understand that people like I feel
like social environment sometimes people
don't understand Q's bro but people
don't understand social cues you know I
hate people that come in your personal
space so you know stalkers you know when
they're there you don't get them right I
keep my space to keep my distance yeah
yeah yeah I keep my distance people like
when I'm like I'll be sat on my desk
sometimes I'm just typing away and
there's a couple women in my office in
their blood James and I turn and they're
literally here if I can feel the
vibrations of your throat or like in my
skull you're way too close and you know
I just want to like arch break my back
and I'm like how do you not understand
this is a social cue how do you not
understand that there's a unspoken
distance that you need to speak to me
from as long as I can hear you clearly
we're cool you know people in a bad mood
and you can tell in a bad mood straight
away and then they treat you like [ __ ]
don't never let me know that you're in a
bad mood bad man when they treat you
like [ __ ] bro they're in a bad mood and
they're just like sorry I'm having a bad
day that's your business
yeah yeah bro that's literally your
business in LA sorry I'm having a [ __ ]
day that's real problem you know I mean
like there's certain people that you
know that when they're in a bad mood you
automatically just laugh don't you find
it not to be sexist okay yes but I find
the female gender do that quite a lot
yeah men if I got normally with men -
men - man they can they're not gonna
push a bad mood on you straightaway yeah
you where's a woman with their emotions
I feel do it more mmm I know you coming
from for sure I know you're coming from
I
so feel like in is different in
different situations so like how do I
explain it men you know I feel like men
who have authoritative positions are
more inclined to do it more you want to
push their way when they're in a bad
mood they feel like they can push their
way around and they feel comfortable
men are more aware that they're doing it
I didn't give a [ __ ] if they're in a
authoritative position whereas I feel
like women in authority positions aren't
as bad
where is Linda big man Linda Linda was
the worst boss I've ever had same to
this day I hope she is it IP is it
brav wind it was cold man she come to
comfort she's like no you're [ __ ] yeah
common actually saw a sister in the shop
down the road yes that is cool yes this
is blessed but Brian Linda used to make
my life hell on purpose and I never knew
where she was a good mood or bad mood
but she used the litter him and my life
had on purpose but yeah as I seen like
yeah I do feel what you're saying in
terms of women are a little bit more
like that in that they'll just they'll
just happily push their bad [ __ ] onto
you in it misery loves company as they
say they want to be miserable but yeah
there's this thing that you said earlier
that made me think and I said I want to
remember it and come back to it that was
like an hour ago
but was it what was it what was it you
said about being being yourself okay so
we were talking about I'm not the father
talking about being present and you were
talking about being yourself as well and
you were talking about the Giza the Giza
that you like on YouTube yeah yeah my
man about talking about being present
and being yourself and I actually find
the whole concept of being yourself like
a very tricky topic sometimes in that
have you ever felt like do you have you
ever felt that like you don't know B or
being yourself means like a
in example for example like there was
time but like basically everyone has a
picture an image of kind of what you are
so excluding Instagram or whatever when
they know you they're your friend they
kind of have an image of that's who you
are
so if you're like the outgoing light for
garius funny character confident and all
that stuff it's very easy to convince
yourself that the or that person because
if someone the words that someone would
use to describe you aren't necessarily
the words that you would use to describe
yourself but you are so aware of that's
the personality that people have
projected onto you because of times
you've been like that that sometimes you
actually think like when you don't feel
that way if there's a week or a day or
an hour that you don't feel confident
you don't feel outgoing you don't feel
like boisterous and all that stuff you
think like what am I actually like you
know I mean do I act like that because
the people want me to have my bow to out
like that because that's that that's
genuinely Who I am
that's it that's interesting because one
thing that like movie addresses is like
emotions are like clouds is what they'll
phrase they say one of his like
paraphrase in a sense that you don't
always if you're angry at a certain time
you're not always gonna be angry it's
just a cloud that you're going for any
or past like cloud yeah so if you're
feeling confident and maybe just a
massive cloud you have because of me
like some people especially being
younger people just think I was
confident and what you've seen is fruits
I think growing up it's an environment
you'll see people that were like hugely
confident younger as I get older to get
less confident and you can tell just by
looking at them how they're carrying
themselves yeah yeah yeah and I feel
like it's constant evolving of yourself
that's true Jimmy you're always changing
you always adapting to send environments
that's very true but I feel like the
core remains the same
yeah your core values yeah yeah the cool
like I said like your core values don't
change really well that's the thing is
like I am
for example like this former like this
podcast thing that I wanted to do and
when I want to do you to tell from stuff
like that or I wanted to have a an
outlet for creative expression and stuff
like that to me that feels very me but
if you if someone was to have like a
snapshot of like my life or someone
who's known me from like a third party
or something like that they might be
thinking what the [ __ ] you talking about
so like when we spoke about Kojo earlier
and how he's tired his ting yeah that's
Kojo that's just him so yes bingo Joe so
like when you summon if is if like yeah
afternoon for five minutes if some comes
are tubular are this guy has a youtube
channel is like very eccentric dance is
loud expressive I on and off camera
yes we that's just him whereas me I'm
very much like growing up but now like I
don't really like social situations very
much I don't like meeting people very
much at all I'm not very outgoing and
confident and stuff like that so for me
to say like almonds that podcast I'll
put myself I wanna I want to post this
and let everyone have an insight to what
I'm actually like someone might like why
that's my you should come feel like
you'll find huge confidence in yeah and
I do and I enjoy it and it's all I think
about it's all I want to do but then
like I also think we need to sit back to
core values when I was a kid when I was
obviously I've been very sporty and I've
done lots of individual sports as well
which is the next like a format of kind
of like self-expression I guess if you
will and also be putting yourself in an
environment where the spotlights on you
I've done quite well and but also when I
was a kid I feel like I had an aspect of
when we did you know me just stupid like
school plays and [ __ ] like that like I
had aspect of that in which was 100 sent
me and I would always be like the guy to
pick for the school play and I would
always want to play like a funny
character and I'd always want to be the
outgoing guy yeah you were even
happy-go-lucky yeah exactly I won't even
positive happy guy and I enjoy that and
they're likes like a core value of mine
that sometimes I've forgotten about when
I'm
thinking about creative [ __ ] I often
have that people often know me as a guy
that is athletic and chatty when you get
to know me but when you meet me like I
probably won't talk to ya and like it's
about like yeah you can have as you grow
older or mood you and you can have
different either clouds or we have
aspects about your personality that
might change or evolve or get lower get
more confident less confident stuff like
that but you always do have certain core
values and there's only one you touch on
those core values and let alive if you
think back to the times where you were
actually like that when you might
surprise yourself initially and be like
mmm and I think that's me can I'm saying
yeah that's the kind of phase I feel
like and going through in a minute okay
I'll go back to core value times whereas
I spent a lot of my life being I don't
know just someone not someone that I'm
not
but falling into a place like you know
when you I feel like with you you've
you've always had this thing of talking
about things in depth yeah you'd like my
new things you pick up on mm-hmm
like you say social cues or different
environments you pick up on and I see
them sometimes as well that you'd like
to express you like to talk about and I
feel like when you have that common
interest and you can reach that
understand them with somebody it is next
time you're in their environment you
might ask where them yeah yeah I mean
just one of them again yeah you know
which I think help if you feel like
you're the only one that understands it
it's like stress yeah yeah when you
understand other people go for that as
well yeah yeah it's so much easier for a
hundred cent man I agree with you man
it's crazy and like always it has
nothing I was gonna say [ __ ] I kind of
remember
I kind of remember about that's cool man
bro we must wrap it up cuz I felt like I
was about to die but yeah
clover Browns scene mm-hmm scene scene
same scene so yeah what's it when this
drops I'll make sure it's all over the
gap semi some [ __ ] please want to wear
it out